he is the popular Mike Florio from pro
football talk live co-host Pro Football
Talk comm joining us from I believe the
barn in West Virginia are you a handyman
around the house there Mike absolutely
not no no no my dad taught me at a young
age that there are people out there who
have families who rely upon the revenue
that comes from fixing things doing
stuff so stimulate the economy your
family hires someone to do these things
camps are opening up a little bit
facilities are opening up but this isn't
Universal here Mike I'm surprised that
the Commissioner is he going to say
something about this there's there any
unfair advantage with some of these
teams having facilities open another
ones not well this is the first moment
where the NFL has reached a point of
disparity Dan 22 teams or there abouts
are in a position where state and local
governments will allow them to open not
all of them are opening right away and
some of them may take a little while but
10 teams or thereabout
can't open at all and look there are
going to be many situations like this if
the NFL is intent on getting 256
regular-season games played there will
be disparities there will be competitive
disadvantages and the NFL is smoothing
this one out by saying no coaches are
permitted at any team facility but still
you've got teams that can fire up the
lawnmower get things rolling again begin
the process of planning for next year's
draft next year's free agency have front
office people there have meetings etc
and as we get closer and closer to the
start of the season Dan I think we're
gonna see more of it and the worst case
scenario and I think we have to be ready
for it some states where stadiums will
be open and thus there will be a
home-field advantage other states where
stadiums won't be open and teams will
have no home-field advantage and I think
that's unavoidable but that's the the
extreme example of where there will be
disadvantages as the NFL tries to play
this season which stadiums do you think
will have found this upcoming season
well I mean look and I'm trying to be
apolitical here but we have all been
paying attention to the states where
there is more commercial activity
despite the pandemic
I think Florida Georgia Texas those are
states that I would point to and say
it's likely that the stadium's will be
open and the message will be we know the
risks you know your health situation as
well as anyone if you want to come to
the game come to the game if you think
you're at risk don't come to the game
and I think states like that and we're
likely to have stadiums open California
New Jersey states that are likely to not
have stadiums open and and yes there
will be a disparity and you know teams
will have to ask themselves do we want
to stay at home for the season and play
in an empty stadium or do we want to go
somewhere else where we could sell
tickets I mean I don't know how robust
the fan base is gonna be if you move the
49ers in Arizona for the year but that's
part of it too because you could have
some fans versus having no fans at all
but I think that's gonna be one of the
practical realities we get deeper into
account the NFL engineers in a sports
equipment company Oakley are looking at
surgical masks here or the n95 material
for these guys - is that gonna be under
your face mask here is a possibility I
don't know whether it's like a covering
for the face mask remember that mask
that Justin Tuck used to wear tight you
couldn't even get a finger through it if
you wanted to I mean will they paste it
over top of that or maybe so I think
there'll be some players just say I
don't want that I want my face mask I
don't want to have this thing where I'm
gonna have a hard time breathing I'm not
worried about getting the corona virus
you know some players who feel that way
you may have some players who want the
extra protection and then of course the
guys who take the extra protection are
going to be targeted to have their faces
spit on by opponents I mean you know how
football players are they're not gonna
they're not gonna we're gonna respect
the guy who's wearing the surgical mask
know they're gonna try to rip it off of
his face and and make him freak out
because all's fair in football at least
that's gonna be the mindset that some
players have so this to me is it's got
the potential to go a lot of different
ways but we have to accept the fact that
football players is still going to be
football players and if there's a guy
out there wearing surgical mask material
there's gonna be somebody else out there
trying to rip it off of his face so I'm
gonna Mike Florio Pro Football Talk Live
co-host with Chris Sims I was
wondering about this mic as we looked at
the schedule in those first four weeks
and I was given a heads up look at the
first four weeks and see if there's a
way they're gonna be NFC AFC matches of
their inner conference interdivisional
location of all of those things and I
started to wonder okay if we took those
first four weeks and we moved it to the
back of the schedule there if the NFL
would they would they take that approach
if it meant we would have a chance at
fans in the stand so we we you're gonna
postpone this and move it to the back so
that gives us an extra month to kind of
figure this out your thoughts on on that
approach here
absolutely Dan absolutely I think the
NFL would explore delaying the start of
the season even if that means removing
those folks for weeks and tacking them
on to the back end of the schedule if it
allows from a political standpoint not
red state blue state politics I'm
talking about working with the
governor's working with the processes
and the protocols behind the scenes to
get people comfortable with taking the
position stadiums are open if you want
to show up if that extra month makes
enough of the difference that all
stadiums will be open I think the NFL is
conducive to doing it but Dan on that
point something else I noticed in the
schedule I think it's been constructed
where if if they don't think delaying
the first four weeks all together would
be beneficial I think they are hell-bent
on going forward with week one when you
look at all those great games they're
scheduled for week one yeah go with week
one and then take a step back and
reassess and if if something goes
haywire you can take the week two games
and all the teams that play in week two
have byes the same week you can push all
those back into the bye weeks week three
week four no divisional games they can
be wiped out or they can be tacked on to
the back end but I think if they do go
forward lift the schedule and without a
delay based on as you suggested a full
month to let stadiums open it seems to
me that they are ready to go week one
and then they would be willing to take a
step back and see if any adjustment is
necessary based upon the consequences of
playing a full slate of games the Rooney
rule surfaced again and now there's
incentive for teams if they're going to
interview minority candidates and maybe
we improve your you know draft stock or
we give you an extra draft pick here
I wonder if this just came down to Eric
the enemy not getting a head coaching
job and and you know to get interviewed
and maybe it's just one of the points
but here he is a great offensive
coordinator with the best offense in
football and you have other people who
are getting jobs here and Eric be enemy
did not get a job if Eric the enemy gets
the job is the Rooney rule working well
I think it's one of the factors Dan that
contributed the critical mass that
caused people to realize something needs
to be done both as the coaches and as
two general managers something coach
Dungy told me yesterday the broadcast of
the draft this year was a key factor in
this decision to make real changes
because we saw the contrast the players
homes
the general managers homes and that
contrast that that lack of diversity
among coaches and front office's came
through loudly and clearly now that we
had cameras in the homes of so many of
the coaches in the GM's that that
actually was a major factor in pushing
this forward and I don't know which
proposals are gonna pass but the idea of
giving incentives giving enhanced draft
status for teams that actually make
minority hires there's a lot of
opposition to that coach Dungy is
against it I think the best move would
be to table that one and allow for more
discussion more ideas maybe other ways
to address the problem short of creating
a reward as coach Dungy says for doing
the right thing yeah I don't like the
reward and I agree with Tony that it
sends the wrong message I just hope that
you get more minorities in coordinating
positions I think that's really the key
and getting you know if they're head
coaching jobs in college or you become a
coordinator and that ability to be able
to then move up and become a head coach
because Eric the enemy should be a head
coach in the NFL and hopefully we'll get
that opportunity and I've said before
Mike not every assistant coach
coordinator deserves to be a head coach
you know Romeo Crennel I don't think was
head coach I don't think Charlie Weis
was a head coach there are certain
personalities where you you know you
have to be ready for that you can be a
great coordinator that doesn't make you
a great coach and I think sometimes we
get caught up in all
you got to give them a head coaching job
that doesn't mean that and plus I think
with african-americans minorities they
have even more pressure to succeed
because if they don't succeed then it
hurts the next one and it's gonna hurt
your chance to get another one so it's a
I mean there's a lot there to unravel
but I don't know if we have a great
answer right now a Dan one key area of
focus that I think the NFL needs to
really be looking at is the entry level
dynamics you got a lot of nepotism you
got a lot of cronyism and you got teams
that do not pay a living wage to the
lowest level employees that's a point
Chris Sims made today on PFT ot because
he was one of those low level guys who
was making peanuts in that first level
job not everyone can say sure I'll work
for nothing guys have families guys
don't have football money in the bank
like Chris Simms had guys don't have
Phil Simms money as a fallback like
Chris Simms had you can't just say sure
I'll work 18 hours a day for nothing if
I got a family at home and I have to
worry about it eliminates a lot of guys
that otherwise could be very good at
that job maybe they need to pay more
money on the way in the door and it will
attract a more diverse group of
candidates oh it's great to talk to you
Michael thank you buddy all right Dan C
pal it's Mike Florio pro football talk
live co-host with Chris Sims also pro
football talk calm